un nouvel accueil pour les restos un 26e
centre d'activité des restos du coeur a
ouvert à magnanville opérationnel depuis
le 21 février dernier cette antenne 2
238 mètres carrés accueille
régulièrement 730 personnes et
distribuer 3000 repas chaque semaine
c'est important pour les personnes que
l'on accueille celles qui ont besoin de
nous d'être accueillis dignement dans
des locaux confortables et puis c'est
important pour nos équipes c'est une
vraie reconnaissance du travail qu'elles
font toute l'année on leur doit de
travailler dans des conditions
confortables dignement de pouvoir venir
souvent et d'avoir la place de pouvoir
réaliser ses activités stocker tous les
produits nous distribuions ouvert suite
à la fermeture de l'antenne de
mantes-la-ville fin 2020 ce nouveau
centre mobilise 24 bénévoles il assure
la distribution des denrées alimentaires
mais aussi un service d aide à la
personne des petites pièces
individuelles permettent aux
bénéficiaires de se confier en toute
confidentialité les personnes qui
franchissent la porte des restos ont non
seulement besoin d'une aide alimentaire
mais très souvent ils ont besoin de se
confier sur leurs problèmes personnels
se devait d aide qu'on pourrait leur
apporter peut-être pour chercher du
travail peut-être pour aller au cinéma
peut-être pour partir en vacances dans
ce centre de magnanville pas de
distribution de repas chauds mais des
dons de produits secs frais surgelés ou
encore des produits bébé un système de
points assure aux bénéficiaires une
répartition équitable on va pas me
donner la même chose à une personne
famille d'une personne de cinq personnes
et donc pour ça pour être le plus juste
possible envers tout le monde on a un
système de points et donc quand une
famille bien un verre elle a un nombre
de points en fonction de la taille de la
famille on va lui faire faire le choix
dans nos réserves en fonction du nombre
de pointe dont elle dispose il ya une
personne qui accueille les personnes à
l'extérieur
appelez on les accompagne pour la
distribution donc c'est en distribution
compagnie et puis il ya un coin bébé
pour les mamans qui vient avec les
enfants en bas âge de 0 à 18 mois le
centre des restos du coeur de
magnanville ferme cet été il ouvrira de
nouveau ses portes à la rentrée le mardi
6 septembre